nicolai bondarenko is on a political
diet for a whole month now the
parliamentarian from Saratov has based
his food budget on a local pensioners
living wage spending just three thousand
five hundred roubles or around forty six
euros to eat the communist party
politician only buys the bare basics and
says he's been hungry all month I want
to prove that living on three thousand
five hundred rubles a month is
impossible
without a negative effect on your health
some accused the politician of populism
others here at sat out of market thanked
him when that anko is pushing to double
the living wage in Russia his campaign
has gotten a huge amount of media
attention along with us a Russian
Federal TV crew is also filming him
preparing his rations but to bondarenko
this is more than just PR and bigger
than his health I don't think that a
month on this diet is enough to
seriously damage a normal person's
health in the long run of course I have
worried about my health
but what I see across the country scares
me much more Bondarenko has documented
the experiment on his video blog and
also shows the debate that kicked it all
off serifs Labour Minister natalia
sokolova
insisted the living wage is enough to
guarantee a balanced diet she was fired
over the remarks in Vantaa incas
argument has grown into a national
debate even on state television but the
government including sedatives new
interim Minister for labour says the
living wage will stay the same for now
it's in solution eating a living wage is
substantiated some based on statistical
calculations and on the law of course we
are striving to improve our approach in
order to work out new more effective
methods for calculating the living wage
that work has begun and should be
finished in 2020 bondarenko z'
experiment has struck a chord beyond
Saratov across russia the standard of
living has been dropping consistently
the government has made having poverty a
goal for the next six years currently
every eighth person lives under the
poverty line which means they earn less
than the living wage brad dr. Rice's are
going up prices for bread and milk are
going up that the existence minimum is
still tiny
I can hardly survive you can only buy
the cheapest products on 3,500 you can
exist on them but not live at his office
at the duma and nikolai bondarenko z'
phone has hardly stopped ringing the
communist politician is convinced his
words about the living wage will be
heard on a national level the only thing
the government can't control is the
Solidarity that unites us the government
would rather lose a finger than a whole
hand Bondarenko is now preparing to take
a draft bill to the Russian Duma he
wants his voice to be heard beyond the
hallways of the local Parliament